he's the editor in chief of the daily
wire syndicated columnist and host of
the Ben Shapiro show then what was your
what are your thoughts when did you hear
that he was going to do this oh I had
heard actually sort of off the radar
last week and had kept it under wraps I
was pretty excited about that it's
obviously an act of not only political
bravery but moral courage to move the
the embassy but but just to recognize
Israel as a Jewish limb as Israel's
capital the absurdity of the u.s. policy
suggesting that Jerusalem was not
Israel's capital has resulted in IDIA
sees like the fact that my niece who was
born in Jerusalem it says on her
passport Jerusalem and then it doesn't
say which country she's from Jerusalem
is only important to the world because
of Judaism it's important to
Christianity because it was first
important to Judaism it's important to
Islam because was forced to important to
Judaism
Jerusalem's mentioned hundreds of times
in the Jewish text Jerusalem is in the
is in the Israeli national anthem the
culmination of Jewish history really was
in 1967 with the recapture and the
unification of Judea of Jerusalem under
Judaic rule the freedom of Jerusalem was
only assured by the way because of that
Jewish rule what what President Trump is
doing is not just a recognition of
reality it's also an act of political
usefulness because all of the
negotiations that been happening for the
last twenty years for most of my
lifetime all of those negotiations have
been preconditions on stupidity that
Israel is going to give up its eternal
capital which is insane I mean in order
to understand how dumb that is you have
to think that for Israel Jerusalem is
about a thousand times more important
than Washington DC is to the United
States I mean the founders put
Washington DC on a swamp because they
just wanted it to be not part of any
States the the reason that Jerusalem is
where it is is because the Bible says it
is where it is there's a religious
adherence to Jerusalem that doesn't
exist for normal capitals around the
world and for President Trump who
recognized that this isn't going
anywhere that the freedom of Israel is
it is just inherently connected with the
freedom of Jerusalem and that any
negotiations that are to take place are
gonna have to be done by the Israelis
themselves and the Israelis are gonna
have to make decisions about what to do
with their capital well it's a ground
shift and it's a recognition of a
reality that's necessary in order for
real peace to be achieved in the region
not based on false stupidities that have
been promulgated for that so they have
six months actually do it they have a
six month way would actually do it
Monday was the deadline to actually make
the announcement so today we're going to
get it today officially at one o'clock
but it will remain a divided city that
won't change is that bother you
well I mean it will remain a divided
city because the fact is that the the
authorities have basically allowed
terrorism to to spread among the
Palestinians and East Jerusalem has
largely been been occupied by the same
people has been occupied poorer for the
last seven decades namely Muslim Muslims
who live there that that part of the
city is very dangerous it's been very
dangerous ever since I can remember long
before I was born the fact is that when
I visited Israel for the first time when
I was 16 years old
Israeli soldiers had to guard us as we
came out of the tunnels under the
western wall into East Jerusalem which
again the capital of Israel if you are a
Jew and you're walking to East Jerusalem
your life is in danger if you're an Arab
when you walk in westeros ylim there's
no problem at all which signifies
exactly why guru salam should be under
Jewish control and not under Muslim
control